america god bless you
[Applause]
[Music]
everybody i'm dave rubin this is the
reuben report direct message it's april
19th 2022 and today
is my last day in studio for a little
bit because i am heading out on tour
tonight that's right i'm gonna be in
west palm beach with donald trump jr
tonight there's a couple tickets left
i'm told about 15 tickets left if you
want to join us tonight in west palm
beach we are in clearwater florida
tomorrow with benny johnson that's the
tampa area then i'm heading over to
raleigh north carolina with andrew
clavin of the daily wire then the willy
wonka of politics uh michael malus will
be joining me in atlanta georgia janmi
park will be joining me in chicago glenn
beck of the blaze will be joining me in
dallas megan mccain formerly of the view
the woman had to sit next to whoopi
goldberg for two years god help her at
the miracle theater in washington dc uh
my good friend megan kelly in west nyack
new york dennis prager
in uh brea california larry elder in
oxnard california uh douglas murray in
san jose california blake masters and
charlie kirk in phoenix arizona brian
callan in denver and then june 2nd
a very
special
guest who i cannot say who it is but
trust me you want to buy tickets it's a
massive theater about a thousand people
in orlando
florida are you following me what's
going on here
june 2nd get tickets to that show if you
have tickets already because we had to
move the date uh your tickets are all
legit you probably got an email about it
it's all good yada yada anyway i'm
seriously looking forward to getting out
and uh and meeting you guys and giving
the one second hug and all that good
stuff and of course you can get tickets
if you have not already at daverubin.com
events and as i said yesterday if you're
struggling financially with all this
craziness in the world if you're a
member of the the military or something
like just contact us let me let me see
what we can do i'll try to help as many
people as possible all right so because
this is my last show in studio for quite
some time i want to continue the theme
that we have been building
and i think dare i say that we've really
hit on something here as you know last
week i announced that we are now in a
post-woke world i think that this elon
musk thing the individual fighting the
system is going to start a series of
cascading events that will lead us to a
post-work world it is not that the woke
world will go away they have destroyed a
lot and they are going to continue
destroying a lot but i think the avenues
off for the rest of us are starting to
present themselves in many many ways uh
oh and by the way as i'm about to go on
tour and have a whole bunch of flights
that i'm about to take uh we will be
covering it momentarily but the federal
mask mandate on planes is gone and you
know why it's gone because one freaking
judge
from tampa florida and we are gonna go
to the courthouse tomorrow and take a
picture and i'm gonna try to say hi to
this guy if possible the judges just
hang out i don't know where judges hang
out i feel like they're always in like a
very stuffy room you know drinking
whiskey or something but i'm gonna go
take a picture at the courthouse because
one man decided to say
no more and then suddenly everyone's
ripping off the mask so we've got videos
of that it's like we all participated in
this sheer lunacy and that's what i mean
about the individual versus the machine
elon musk is one man this federal judge
is one man i am one man you are one man
or woman i'm not a biologist what do i
know but we can beat this thing and that
is the plan and i'm gonna lay out some
other ways we can beat it over the
course of the next half hour before
though i get to any of that i am very
excited to share this new sponsor with
you we just got this incredible box just
showed up at our house the other day
look at these beautiful knives i gotta
show you one before i start talking
about it let me not chop my head off i
mean look at these gorgeous japanese
steel knives uh ladies and gentlemen
it's time to up your kitchen knife game
using kamikodo knives using traditional
techniques kamikoto crafts beautiful
knives using steel source from japan
each blade is made with techniques that
have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths they come in
a beautiful heavy-duty ash wood box look
at that right there and every blade is
individually inspected and comes with a
lifetime guarantee because of their
single bevel edge kamikoto knives can
achieve a wickedly sharp edge the kind
you just can't get with other knives
these are cut through your rib eye like
butter sharp kamikoto knives are used by
several chefs working at michelin star
restaurants around the world they make
amazing gifts that come in beautiful
boxes you can maintain each knife's edge
with one of kamikoto's sharpening wet
stones and like i said they're so
confident in their product that each and
every knife comes with a lifetime
guarantee if you go ahead and buy now
kamikoto is offering uh an extra fifty
dollars off site-wide on top of their
special offers go to commiecodo.com and
use the code ruben for an extra 50 bucks
that's
k-a-m-i-k-o-t-o dot com slash reuben
kamikodo slash reuben and uh get
yourself some nice i mean look how
freaking gorgeous these things are like
this is truly
look at this beauty look at this thing
like come on man
that is a beautiful piece of steel right
there
i may have to bring this on tour well
actually now that they got rid of the
mass mandate on planes i guess i don't
need to bring knives anymore all right
so here's what we're going to show you
because i believe we are starting to
enter this post-woke world two things
are going to start becoming obvious the
old system as i said it's not going to
completely go away of course it's not
and it's going to it's going to lash out
in all sorts of
weird and crazy ways but we will start
building some new things but i don't
think these people are sending their
best to the best and that biden video
that we showed you up top i mean the is
shaking hands with an imaginary friend
he has no idea where he is and it is
starting to become obvious to the point
that his uh his approval ratings are
just tanking beyond belief we've got
some video here from fox news
and john the first one of those polls
that you mentioned looks at the
president's overall approval rating and
it is down all the way down to 33
percent according to uh quinnipiac and
that has more than half the adults
pulled 54 percent disapproving that is
as republican critics say the reason for
this is the i word inflation
if you look at his approval numbers
they're
quite low and here in iowa everyone's
feeling the pinch of inflation they're
filling the pinch of
you know empty store shelves uh not
having goods whether it's in our
manufacturing sector or agricultural
sector even our health care sector
there's another new poll by gallup that
finds the president in real trouble with
young voters he is tanking with
generation z that's people born between
97 and 04 they are giving him a 60
they gave him a 60 approval when he came
to the white house last year now he's
all the way down to 39
that is down 21 points
okay so the numbers are absolutely
cratering and they should be cratering
now i although i am gen z i'm 45 years
old i'm right smack dab in the middle of
gen z and it's very unfortunate actually
that gen z hasn't taken over yet i think
you're about to see perhaps gen z taking
over right elon musk gen z we're
starting to see the people who are
supposed to be in charge right now gen z
if you're late 30s to say early 50s
you're young enough but have a little
world behind you you're strong you're
focused you're ready to fight the world
still you have experience and all of
those things uh you should be in charge
right now like that's the group the age
of people that should be in charge and
these people whether it is joe biden or
nancy pelosi or some of these other
octogenarians they should be stepping
aside right uh they should be stepping
aside sorry i'm talking about gen x i am
gen x not gen z because i got a lot of
things flashing in front of me today
we're really trying to pack in a show on
my last day here um so gen
x should be in charge right now gen z
right behind us they should be in charge
pretty freaking soon that that basically
is the point there and that everyone is
now seeing that this biden thing ain't
working but joe biden did uh
give a little talk to the to the good
people the good americans over on easter
sunday and then he got interrupted by
his chief of staff
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what is going on here people the guy
dressed as the bunny
just ushered joe biden away from the
people
who is that man in the money
and who gave him the authority to tell
the president to walk away as opposed to
an aide just walking up to him like what
is really going on here and then the
constant just like the shaking of the
hand the imaginary hand and then not
knowing where he is just this constant
befuddled thing but the point is and the
reason i'm showing this is actually not
to mock him today it's to show you that
the thing ain't working and people can
see it so the proof is in the pudding
when you see
millennials gen z gen x when you see
those numbers just absolutely dumping
out it's because whether the
administration wants you to see it or
not whether the mainstream media wants
you to see or not people can see it and
it's like this thing ain't working
putting aside inflation
and supply chain and all of those other
things it's also like oh the guy's
shaking hands with an imaginary friend
we got a problem on our head and you
know we got a problem in our hand when
even msnbc the mental institution known
as msnbc they're acknowledging the
disaster
inflation's soaring and it's at a pace
we haven't seen in nearly two
generations and as costs continue to
rise the president has seen his standing
in the polls continue to decline a new
cnbc survey out this morning
uh conducted by the same two polling
firms to do the nbc news poll have
president biden's job approval rating at
a lackluster 38 percent it's down three
points since their december survey 15
points underwater that's down two points
from our survey again same two polling
firms dnr polling firms that we use uh
do this work for cnbc as well when you
look deeper into this poll it sure looks
like inflation and the overall economic
attitudes are just driving those numbers
48
say that the cost of living is the most
important issue facing america right now
it's by far the top issue and more than
any other age group
you've been hearing about these problems
with biden with young voters
voters under 35 this important part of
the biden coalition say this is the most
important issue and it's ahead of
everybody and and these folks think the
economy is in worship than any other age
group folks under 35 overall president
biden's approval on the economy sits
at just 35 percent you can see the job
approval and the economic numbers are
essentially starting to be uh in line
notably despite biden's efforts to tout
strong job growth and gdp a majority 56
believe there will be an economic
recession during the next 12 months
bottom line americans see rising costs
as the single sign of pending economic
doom in the white house with some
serious political challenges on this
issue because what it takes to lower
inflation
it's not something you want to run on
okay so chuck todd is uh he's sad he's
upset this ain't good and by the way i
don't want the economy to tank you may
remember that very famous clip a couple
years ago in the middle of the trump
presidency when things were going pretty
damn well when bill maher who obviously
was no trump supporter was saying that
he would be happy if there was an
economic disaster and a recession
because that would get rid of trump now
i don't want that to happen i wish
everything could turn around right now i
really do and even if that meant that
perhaps joe biden had to stick around
longer even though it's fairly obvious
he's not going to be a two-term
president if he even makes it that long
i would be okay with that because i'm an
american first right so put aside
partisan stuff or this whatever i think
of the administration or these clowns or
sake or the rest of them i believe in
america and i want good decent americans
to be living a good life but chuck
todd's very depressed about this because
he knows what that all leads to is his
guys the dems are losing power
and now i want to show you a little bit
from gallup just in terms of that loss
of influence within young people
by the biden administration this is the
declines that have hit them since
january 2021 this gets back to the gen z
gen x millennials thing so gen z
it has hit
a negative 21 points since january 21 in
terms of support for biden millennials
down 19 and my guys uh gen x those
middle agers down 15 boomers are down uh
seven traditionalists are basically
rocking the same and and the total in
essence is around 14 points down this is
good you really have to understand this
is good it doesn't mean that all the
things that are happening are good right
inflation's not good the price of cost
uh the price of goods is not good uh
whatever is going on with this war that
we're either in or not in is not good
the endless printing of money is not
good we get all that but that people
that it's now it's baked into the
numbers now and numbers are real
these guys don't believe numbers are
real but numbers actually are real
the numbers going down show you the
people are starting to wake up that they
have just had it and perhaps it's not
just the economic stuff perhaps perhaps
they've had it with the woke stuff and
the gender stuff and the race stuff and
all of the stuff stuff and they've also
had it with the pandemic stuff but the
administration has gone so deep that
they cannot stop they simply cannot stop
here is biden covet advisor ashish ja
saying how the pandemic just ain't over
is cove is still a crisis
it is still a real challenge for our
country right i mean if you look at this
we still have lots of people getting
infected 400 americans are still 4-500
americans are still dying every day of
this virus
and we have seen pretty substantial
evolution of this virus over time so the
pandemic is not over as much as we all
wish it were
we were in much much better shape than
we were but we've got to keep plugging
away
at managing this virus and getting it
under better control so we can get back
with to our lives
okay so look the pandemic is not over is
a meaningless statement does kovid exist
yes has it existed for two years yes
have they fudged with the numbers yes
have they lied about the ways that you
can keep yourself safe yes have they
took incredible
overreach in terms of what you have to
do with your own body and medical
privacy yes has this entire thing been a
freaking disaster yes and has two weeks
to flatten the curve become over two
years later we're still talking about
this nonsense because we want to control
you
yes
so they still want more and more and
more and as i said we're going to get in
a moment to the story about the judge
who by the way is a female i think i
implied she was a male but again i'm not
a biologist
um we're gonna get more to the judge the
federal judge here in tampa florida who
said no more mass mandates and now
everyone's throwing them off we all we
all played along with this and now
everyone's just ripping them off just
like that but what does this lead to
this leads again to a theme that i've
been talking about if enough
good liberals whoever is out there that
if you are just a good borderline
liberal or someone who's not
particularly political you just have to
not vote for democrats right now you
must vote for republicans for now and
then we can pick up the pieces after
that's where we're at so i want to link
that to one of the things that i've been
talking about a lot over the last month
uh something from uh bill maher as you
know he was on the joe rogan podcast a
couple weeks ago and even he
is actually starting to get it and i am
really doing my best to push him to
fully
accept
the truth
i mean i say this all the time because
the uh
percentage of
graft keeps getting
higher and higher now we found out
recently that something like oh i'm
going to get the number wrong maybe you
can look it up on your magic light box
but
like 20 percent i think of the uh
unemployment checks we passed out during
covet were complete fraud mere pittance
[Laughter]
the uh ppp yeah oh my god so many people
got arrested for having lamborghinis and
[ __ ] right
i mean jk rowling got money no she did
it yeah for her broadway show what
because if she didn't she'd be living in
her car joe ah
she got money from that that's hilarious
everybody got money tom brady so crazy
and like
when you look at some of the percent and
like the number for uh to build a house
for the homeless in l.a
has risen to eight hundred and thirty
seven thousand amir pittance bill maher
amir pins from these greedy billionaires
out there we need to talk to them all if
i'm complaining about that again to your
point about a republican idea people
would say oh you're complaining about
government spending money and my answer
is okay but is there any number at which
point i am not
tipped over into the republican side
right that i can't complain about money
that is just being stolen
right i mean we i i totally as a good
liberal i totally accept the notion that
as someone once said you cannot transfer
money except with a leaky bucket i get
it it can't be perfect
but
is it
20 what is that is there no number
for which i cannot remonstrate against
ah he's so close
no bill there is no number
your guys the guy that you supported joe
biden the party that you support there
is no number that will ever be enough
they make up the numbers
they pour money onto all of these
programs that destroy the very place
that you live in los angeles that has
been destroyed by homelessness and drug
use and crime they usher in all of those
things and i get it he's saying well i'm
in essence he's saying i'm a guilty
liberal so i still want to do these
things get over it man like you gotta
get over it otherwise they will all show
up at your multi-million dollar house
one day that's just how it is and you'll
have no one to blame but yourself when
you call the police and say boy there's
an awful lot of antifa people and
homeless people and everything else
climbing over the gate right now i'm
very upset about this also i just want
to say one sort of side thing and maybe
this is me at 45 years old as i said it
is middle age what can i do uh and and i
guess having become a little more
conservative
over the years but there's something
about watching people smoke pot and have
a conversation that seems very
sort of gross to me i'm not against pot
and occasionally i smoke some weed and i
watch seinfeld and i go to bed that's
pretty much my pot experience these days
and people can smoke pot for any reasons
they want but there's something about
like you're you got two guys here who
are pretty freaking influential in the
world what's the reason they have to get
stoned to have that conversation i don't
know do i man do i get i sound like a
stodgy old i sound like mr burns or
something [ __ ]
all right let's move on uh the big story
yesterday is that the federal mass
mandate
on planes is over and let me just tell
you as a person who is about to go on
tour and i've got probably i don't know
20 30 flights coming up in the next
couple weeks i am freaking thrilled
about this just two days ago
coming back from jersey for passover i
was reprimanded several times on the
plane i was woken up once to have the
mask put above my nose
i want to also say that i have not
complied at an airport in months and
months over a year
the second i get off the plane i take
off my mask i'm very proud it was
michael over there who usually my
producer who travels with me who from
day one was like i'm just not doing it
and he got me to just not do it and in
the airports i never did it a lot of
times i'd get high-fived by people or
there's a nod of of oh you're an actual
human being uh and there's no we were
all policing ourselves the whole time i
never found that there were authorities
looking for people we were all doing it
to ourselves the entire time well a
federal judge in tampa has reversed this
thing and suddenly everyone's ripping
off the mask so it's as if we all knew
that it was [ __ ] we all everyone was
doing it we all knew it was [ __ ] we
were all afraid of being looked at or
pointed at oh my god you're a bad person
you break the rules
well anyway uh
the machine
and again let's get back to the theme
the theme is the machine ain't gonna
stop
but i think a lot of people are gonna
start paying less attention to the
machine as they make decisions for
themselves so let's first do the machine
part
here's anthony fauci hopefully we're not
going to have to show much more him
praising china's lockdowns how
concerning is the outbreak in china we
see the lockdown in shanghai and the
state department now ordering families
out all non-essential workers out of
shanghai
well china has has a number of problems
two of which are
that their complete
lockdown
which was their approach a strictest
lockdown that you'd never be able to
implement
in the united states
although that prevents the spread of
infection and remember early on
they were saying and i think accurately
that they were doing better than almost
anybody else but lockdown has its
consequences you use lockdowns
to get people vaccinated so that when
you open up
you won't have a surge
of infections because you're dealing
with an immunologically naive population
to the virus because they've not really
been exposed because of the lockdown
the problem is that the vaccines that
they've been using are not nearly as
effective
as the vaccines that are used in the
united states the uk eu and other places
rod the man is an absolute
fraud and let's just be clear about
saying he is the highest paid person
on the federal government dole okay can
you get uh fauci's salary i think it's
about 450 000 a year federal government
so i hear a lot of people often say he's
given his life to science he's just a
man of science who wants to do good
things it's like he's made a [ __ ] load
of money while doing it okay i don't
begrudge anyone making money although i
sort of begrudge uh state employees
doing it especially state employees who
are doing things to harm other people of
the country but yes he makes 417
000 a year salary he got a book deal he
got a netflix deal think of all the
speaking deals the way he's worshiped
wherever he goes and he kind of admires
china the way they're using lockdowns to
make things happen but he says two
interesting things there he says
lockdown prevents the spread of
infection please find me a study that
shows that
please
someone proved me wrong i'm going out on
tour but i will do a show with my phone
i will do a selfie show to say anthony
fauci i'm sorry there is no evidence of
it and it's not just that there's no
evidence of it there is plenty of
evidence that lockdowns caused a hundred
other problems
economic problems depression alcoholism
all of those things so he just lied
about that and then he goes
they were saying they were doing better
than anyone else oh you don't say the
authoritarian communist chinese
government was saying if they lock down
their people and we showed you last week
the video of all the people in shanghai
screaming that are trapped in their
homes with no food or running water or
working toilets you don't say that the
chinese government that loves to control
people just the way our government would
love to if there wasn't enough of us who
would fight um and thank god that there
are uh that they they might lie you
think that they might is it possible am
i nuts that the communists might lie
about some stuff
well sorry fouchy cause your
authoritarian control is going away and
it's going away in real time
that is right a district a middle
district judge of florida tampa division
we've got some info here the court has
declared unlawful the backs the mass
mandate and vacates the mass mandate
remanding it to the cdc for further
proceedings consistent with this order
so just you really need to understand
what just happened here
all it took was one federal judge i
don't know who this federal judge is do
we have a name can i get a name on this
chick
this chicker dude although i'm told
she's a woman
i want a name i'm told she's appointed
by she was appointed by that orange man
scary donald trump but do you see what
happened here one person one judge we
got a lot of federal judges in this
country one federal judge finally said
enough is enough and now we all know
we're in a better situation we all know
we're in a better situation we'll get
her name in just a second here is video
of people taking their masks off on a
plane just as it is announced april 18
the dubai administration announced that
the transportation security
administration will no longer enforce
the federal mandate
requiring mass in all u.s airports
non-foreign aircraft
[Applause]
finally effective immediately
immediately mass are optional for all
airport employees crew members and
customers inside us airports and onboard
aircraft
it's beautiful and it's also very scary
at the exact same time because here you
have all these people whether it's the
pilot who's an employee whether it's all
the people are on the plane they all did
what they were supposed to do they were
all good citizens and they behaved all
day long and you get a cookie and you're
good meaning you put the mask on you sat
there quietly you didn't talk you never
said hi to a neighbor anymore or any of
those things we destroyed so much of the
fabric of our societies and we did it
because we were all policing ourselves
and there just wasn't enough of us
willing to say enough is enough
so that's the sad part about it but then
the beautiful part is people don't want
to live like this anymore and finally
one person did something and one
person's decision
started freeing the people and dare i
link this back to that moses guy and the
passover story i think there's a little
something there i really do and dare i
link this back to elon musk fighting
twitter and the machine one guy can do
something the judge's name by the way is
judge catherine kimball mizell she is 35
years old she is a young lady she is a
trump appointed judge and she
god bless that woman i want to meet that
woman we're going to the courthouse
tomorrow if anyone wants to meet me at
the tampa bay courthouse tomorrow i'm
just going to be i'm going to show up
i'm going to bring her a coffee or
something
but people have wanted this for a long
time and we all knew it was the right
thing to do and this doesn't preclude
you from wearing a mask on a plane if
you want to you can wear a mask and a
face shield and you can wrap your head
in saran wrap and continue to do all of
those things if you so wish you could do
all of those things okay
but everyone's wanted to get rid of it
this is video from a little while ago
the delta ceo talking about how enough
is enough but he just didn't have the
power i guess he could have put his neck
out there but he just didn't have the
power in his mind to do anything about
it we think from the pandemic stage to
the endemic stage and we need to learn
how to live with it without being so
restricted
delta airlines ceo at bastion also
pointing to the challenges his own crew
members face are you comfortable with
your passengers dropping masks now
i think our customers are comfortable uh
dropping masks i think our employees are
tired of wearing masks our employees
especially on those on board those
flights are tired of policing mass
it's interesting what he's saying there
because you don't become the delta ceo
without having some power it's like how
do you become the disney ceo you have to
know how to do business you have to have
a pretty good resume so he's asked you
know like do you want to get rid of this
he's in essence what he's being asked
well everyone else wants to get rid of
it we're trying to figure it out but
imagine if he as a ceo would have just
said hey
me and my airline we're not going to
comply and then six months ago we would
have sort of sort of started this war
between airlines and the cdc i think we
could have got out of this thing much
much earlier so again one person the
delta ceo is one guy the tampa bay
federal judge is one gal elon musk is
one guy
this
am i am i making myself clear today i
feel like i'm making myself clear days
and am i beating this thing into the
ground yeah
but
it's not just that we have to push back
we have to keep asking questions of the
people who are the liars and who has
been basically the chief architect of
the lies lately of course it is this jen
sake oh and by the way uh as you guys
know since i'm going out on tour tonight
i think what we're gonna do on all tour
stops is every time i say sake on stage
everyone has to drink people are gonna
be wasted within five minutes i think
that's what we're gonna do it's the sake
drinking game okay and i'll do it too
i'm gonna have some tequila on stage if
i say sake
let's roll uh anyway this audio leaked
of her going after peter ducey uh at
this show she was doing and just she's
ugh i do not like this woman
okay before we go yeah i have to ask you
a question okay because we have to talk
about peter ducey for one second sure
okay
okay
[Applause]
is he
a stupid son of a [ __ ]
or
does he play a stupid son of a [ __ ] on
tv
[Applause]
okay um
[Music]
well
um
he works for a network
okay that um provides people with
questions
that nothing personal to any individual
including peter ducey but might make
anyone sound like a stupid son of a
[ __ ]
she's just awful like jen saki you're
just an awful person and when you leave
this job you're still going to be an
awful person you're going to be an awful
host at msnbc nobody watches msnbc by
the way i'm very proud to tell you guys
that in the last couple of weeks our
numbers have absolutely exploded our
numbers here last month was our best
month ever
on youtube despite the fact that we're
blowing up on rumble and i'm really
trying to push everybody over to rumble
and to the blaze uh our numbers last
month on youtube were like 25 percent
higher than ever before our live streams
each day are averaging about 200 000
views at this point by the end of the
day uh which they would kill for at cnn
i got three guys that work for me and i
give them chipotle that's all i do okay
uh nobody is paying attention to these
people anymore but it's just the
smugness it's the smugness you know
peter ducey the guy's actually asking
legit questions and why does she think
that he's a son of a [ __ ] or why does
she think that the network executives
that he works for are sons of [ __ ]
it's because she doesn't want to say
anything true and people who like to lie
for a living or who
their primary driver is to lie and to
propagandize they don't like people who
do that peter ducey has done nothing
other than ask legit questions how many
videos have we showed you guys right
here so again this is a good sign
watching
the approval ratings tank of joe biden
good sign people waking up exposing the
nonsense of gensake good sign mask
mandates going away good sign things are
happening so let's end on hope how do
you do it well you take say the desantis
younkin playbook right desantis
obviously governor here in florida
yunkan glen yunken obviously governor in
virginia you take the playbook of
fighting the system and you fight it
because they too are just one man each
one of them
one man who said enough is enough i'm
gonna fight for the right things so if
you want to see a little bit about
what's going on right here in florida
right now i've referenced this a couple
times on the show but the registration
the party registration here is just
phenomenal what's going on here in
florida we've got mci maps some info
from mci maps how has the voter
registration in florida changed from
october 2020 to february 2022 florida
went from a 0.9 democrat advantage to a
0.6 gop advantage republicans have
approved improved across all counties
except for seminole so this is a great
sign the numbers are something like it
was something like a 200 000
voter registration advantage for dems
when
desantis took office and it's something
like 80 000 more republicans right now
now again i don't even say that to be
partisan i say that to be sane that's
all i mean by that that you just cannot
vote for democrats anymore who have
ushered in
all of this complete nonsense and of
course you guys all know the the glenn
younkin situation that glenn younkin won
because he in effect uh fought back
against critical race there even
politico had to admit it republican
glenn younkin won the virginia
governor's race a sign of the gop's
comeback after losing the presidency and
the senate in last election and what did
that entire race boil down to it boiled
down to parents not wanting their kids
to be taught
racism critical race theory which in
essence is neo-racism in school so
people can wake up they are waking up
and i am looking forward to getting out
on the road and talking to you awake but
not woke people we got a cold clothes
for you i want to get to a couple
comments and then i'll just have a
couple more thoughts on the tour and
then i'm out of here for a little bit
i'm going to miss the freaking show i've
been loving it more than ever truly
truly uh pat says bill maher is sitting
in front of the red curtain from twin
peaks this may explain his ideological
inconsistencies i never watched twin
peaks what does that mean i have no did
you watch twin peaks you watch twin
peaks does it mean something does the
reference make sense
yes i'm getting a thumbs up that your
reference makes sense it's it's lost on
me
red curtain twin peaks yeah it's a
little bit of i'll do a curtain thing
for you it's a little bit of
the curtain in wizard of oz in that bill
maher has seen what's going on behind
the curtain but then he keeps putting
the curtain back that's a curtain
reference that i can do right he's
seeing that the democrat party is all
[ __ ] he's seeing that the policies
are all nonsense he's seeing that the
vote the people he's voting for are
destroying the life that he wishes to
lead but then he's seeing it he's going
oh [ __ ] and then he pulls the curtain
back so curtains but okay i'm going to
do a little more research on this red
curtain twin peaks i've heard twin peaks
is good
tyler says i'll definitely miss dave's
direct messages while on tour it helps
keep me sane okay so here's the deal i
will be back on may 2nd because then we
have about a 10-day break before i hit
the final leg of the tour um and then we
may add some sporadic stops but i the
truth is as much as i love touring and
i'm so psyched to get out there tonight
um you know we have kids coming and i
want to try to enjoy my last bit of the
life that i've known for quite some time
and you know we're in a new house in a
new state here and i want to enjoy a
little bit of uh
of the beginning of the summer and all
that here and get some things in order
uh so we will be back may 2nd but by the
way my guys are going to be coming with
me on tour and we're going to be taping
stuff and i think we'll do some behind
the scenes things and we'll try to do
some uh some live stream stuff i think
we'll probably keep as much of that uh
just on locals that that's the beauty of
being a locals member you know you guys
can basically be on on the road with me
so we'll try to do a lot over there
amy says i'll be front row vip tomorrow
in clear water do i get a two second hug
you know the thing is
with the hugs amy if i say right now amy
you get the two second hug then everyone
wants the two second hug this goes back
to say fourth grade you bring the
cupcakes for your birthday you know what
i'm talking about right you bring the
cupcakes and you got four good friends
and you say mom i want to bring you know
john and bob and jim and ted the
cupcakes i don't want everybody to have
the cupcakes but then what do they
always say no you have to bring
everybody the cupcakes they because they
don't want that kid that nobody likes to
not have a cupcake so the problem is if
i give you the two second hug
then i gotta give it to everybody but
this is my last day in studio and
you're a good woman amy and all right
anyone named amy tomorrow at the
clearwater show i will give the
two-second hug to you michael can you
make note of that in the official tour
document thank you okay
guys if you want to join me on tour it
kicks off tonight in west palm there's a
couple tickets left you can join me and
donald trump jr daverubin.com events and
then i'm just bouncing all over the
place i think i got eight shows in a row
it's gonna be a crazy eight days
uh crazy eight days that's right west
palm clearwater raleigh north carolina
atlanta chicago dallas dc west nyack
brea oxnard san jose phoenix denver and
orlando and reminder again orlando trust
me
you were you want to fly in if you don't
live in florida or take a road trip you
want to come to this show it is going to
be the perfect way to end this thing i
can announce the guest on may 2nd but
tickets are already selling fast because
i've been hinting at it
you want to come to this one you want to
come to this one um
it's in orlando
you want to come to this show you got it
people uh part one of my interview with
carrie lake she is running for governor
of arizona trump endorsed candidate
really liked her really like outspoken
you know when you meet one of these
people that just says what they think
she just says what she thinks part one
is up on on youtube right now full
things up over on locals and uh all
right i'm i'm a little melancholy now
that i have to head out on tour because
uh i'm gonna miss you good people but i
hope to see as many of you as possible
one more time in case you have not been
listening for the last month join me out
on the road daverubin.com
slash events every single ticket
comes with a book
and uh if you if you bring the book up
to me during the meet and greet i'll
sign it for you because that's the type
of guy i am there you go uh thank you
guys for watching i've really
enjoyed the shows over the last couple
weeks more than ever truly and i have no
doubt that i'll come back sort of fresh
and refreshed and with new thoughts
after meeting people you know that's the
thing when you actually get out there
and meet people and travel the country
it starts sparking some thoughts so if
you if you've enjoyed what's been going
on over the last couple months i think
it will be uh doubly enjoyable if i do
say my so myself when i get back so i
thank you guys for watching i'm looking
forward to getting out there and meeting
you and we leave you with a cold clothes
[Music]
[Applause]
you